There's a scarcity of low-skilled labor,...
...so instead of paying a sales clerk to sit and collect your money...
...when you buy a piece of gum,...
...they just put it in a machine and automate the whole thing.
And the same goes for real estate.
Japan is one of the densest countries in the world.
93 percent of the population lives in cities.
People literally live in apartments smaller than your SUV.
So instead of paying a lot of money for a storefront,...
...retailers will just slip a little machine into an alleyway...
...to save  a lot of money and they can still turn a really good profit.
According to one essay that I read from a Japanese economist here in Tokyo,...
...the bigger explanation for the vending machines...
...is a fascination or even an obsession with automation and robotics.